buckle up fellow adventurers we're
heading back to bandura that's right the
wait for avatar 2 the way of water has
finally come to an end and to say it
lightly it's going to be well worth the
wait there's so many secrets surrounding
the making of this massive blockbuster
so hold your breath we're diving deep
into it
number one james cameron was determined
in making a splash return to the cinemas
so much so that he was having his cast
take dunks in a giant pool for days on
end his realistic approach to shooting
in the specific environment led
designers to construct a massive 900 000
gallon water tank for the actors to
basically live in james would sit and
direct his actors from above and kate
winslet would simply hold her breath
till the take was done we quite
literally mean that but we'll get more
into that a little later for now let's
just stay a little jealous over the paid
pool days the cast got during principal
photography
number two now you might be thinking
filming in a giant water tank is cool
and all but how'd they do the incredible
motion capture work down there well the
answer is simple james cameron and a
whole lot of money and time we are
already aware of this creativity and
dedication to every film project but he
literally developed new motion capture
technology to use in the water all it
took was a little brain power and a ton
of ping pong balls this tech allowed
visual effects editors to more
realistically depict the way water
interacts with the characters bodies but
sometimes the process became a little
painstaking according to cameron scuba
bubbles would create too much noise in
our performance capture system so no
matter how long the scene took if it
took two three four minutes to shoot
everybody was holding their breath
number three so if you've held your
breath up until this point congrats
that's much longer than we ever could
but you're not much of a record breaker
considering kate winslet holds the
breath-holding title for a whopping 7
minutes and 30 seconds she was very
proud of her accomplishment and having
trained for months with navy seals on
the technique it looks like she got the
hang of it i learned how to breath hold
and held my breath for seven minutes
which is completely true and i'm very
proud of that tom cruise may need to
take a few pointers from her and a few
from sigourney weaver too that's right
at 72 years of age weaver was able to
hold her breath for just over 6 minutes
both of these actresses really deserve a
breather after the films finished
shooting
number 4 the titanic film mastermind
decided to ditch the old ship tech and
bring on a couple new ones and being
that this is cameron's film they had to
create them both on a massive scale with
the sneak peek at the matador and
pikador we can surmise that they are
just cooler versions of submarines and
boats
number five dipping a camera underwater
or any other electronic is probably not
the best idea and with that in mind
cinematographer and camera inventor paw
will actually needed to whip up a camera
to do the job right actol just decided
to upgrade his camera to shoot 6k
footage at a distance of 20 feet this
way filmmakers can get the quality they
want without risk of damage to the
equipment
number six acting underwater is
difficult enough but can you imagine
dancing underwater yeah we couldn't and
it looked like the rest of the cast
opted out of this venture because james
went ahead and hired trained aquatic
dancers to perform the underwater
numbers
number seven the cast and crew of the
avatar franchise really grew close and
became attached to the characters
specifically for zoe saldana who played
the fierceness teary of pandora she has
become so invested in her character that
she got very emotional after a special
preview of avatar 2 by just watching a
mere 20 minutes of the film zoe cried
and cheered for her character's journey
i was speechless i just i i was moved to
tears if this preview made her feel this
way can you imagine how the theaters
will be after watching the entire thing
a tissue box with the purchase of every
movie ticket would be a big plus
number eight director james cameron has
a plan and this complex plan involves at
least three more sequels we haven't even
watched the second one however it seems
he just can't wait to make them with the
comments we've heard by the actors of
the movie they seem to be all exhausted
from shooting two movies at a time i
just sit here at my desk and i cry all
day long there's no solid news as to
when they will be filming the others but
we can imagine it will be soon cameron
knows the pressures of making sequels
but with the innovations he's made to
make the film perfect we can expect he
knows what he's doing as much of the
hard work that is put in means more
magic for the audiences so we guess it's
a win-win for both parties
number nine enough about our praises for
the great james cameron let's get the
gas take on their boss no bias of course
you know jim he's a very loyal man he
keeps the same people on board but all
that aside we can't imagine why they'd
work with him for so long and show so
much praise for his work if they didn't
like working with them plus they're
already at the point of nicknames in
their friendship with him which means
they're basically family now jim trusts
the people that he surrounds us with and
we all trust in him number 10 a
successful sequel must take the best
from the first and add brand new aspects
and well james looks to be pretty well
versed in audience expectations and
won't fail to impress since he had such
a long time to plan out the franchise he
decided to do a little research in the
ocean this made some pretty big
headlines back in the day and he really
credits the success of those voyages as
huge inspirations for the ocean
environment of avatar 2.
number 11 it's been over 10 years since
avatar hit the silver screens the
multi-billion dollar film united some of
the finest actors of their generations
with cameron bringing back the original
cast and characters it seems very
surreal to everyone on set like zoe
being attached to her character so is
everyone of the actors she's my favorite
i've gotten to be able to live in her
skin they not only loved their newfound
family but they also really wanted to
get going on another james cameron
spectacle
number 12 we now know that the planning
of the avatar franchise started being
planned as far back as 2012 but what
took so long some can say that james's
ocean excursions were to blame as we
learn more and more about the scale of
the production in general it looks like
james took a decade-long hiatus to play
the right moves
number 13 secret secrets are no fun
unless you're sam worthington who really
thinks they're amusing no he's not
rubbing it in our faces he's actually
keeping the secret safe for our own
enjoyment i like the surprise of it i
like that we've been very secretive for
the last 15 years and while some of the
cast knows the inner workings of the
story they too just want us to enjoy a
fresh new take
number 14. the family is all united and
stronger than ever with a few hints at
the upcoming plot james had just a taste
to give us they have family bonds they
teach
each other they have taught culture as
this sequel will take place 15 years
after the original sully has created a
family and protected it for a very long
time and with the original enemies
making a return invasion of pandora this
one's going to be all about surviving as
a family number 15 when cinema lovers
think of family who else comes to mind
more than vin diesel aside from any
pandora family barbecues finn was
announced to be in the film well maybe
not officially announced but after
meeting a few times with cameron diesel
had this to say i have spent time with
him but i have not filmed yet i love
james cameron and i love the series i
think it's safe to say that we will be
working together james cameron is a
revolutionary director and seems to hold
one simple motto if you can't do it all
don't do it at all we've been patiently
waiting for the next step in the journey
of pandora and the cast all assures us
it will deliver so what environment do
you think james will pick next for
avatar 3 let us know in the comments